(audience applauding)
My next guest tonight is
a bug expert and founder
of the Montreal Insectarium
and Montreal Quebec.
And he's brought a few
of his insect friends.
Please, welcome Georges Brossard.
(audience clapping)
Georges, how are you?
Let me explain very quickly
a little tension between Georges and I.
You see you are French Canadian.
You were from Quebec.
We sent Triumph the
Insult Comic Dog there,
a little while ago.
A little angry about that.
(audience laughing)
I apologize. And now we make nice.
It's all good.
I would like to shake hands
after the show with you.
After the show?
After the show.
Yes, but first you feel that I need
to do some penance for
what happened in Quebec,
Is that right?
Yes, how is that you
I don't fool around with the
pot, like New York Rangers.
So let's proceed.
Yes,
Yes, yes indeed! Yes, yes,
Yes, yes, yes, let's proceed yes!
(audience clapping)
Well said Okay.
We acknowledge that you
were not fully responsible
Of that situation
That's true.
And as a man of honor...
The problem was out of control,
there's nothing I could do.
Yes, but as a man of honor
Yes,
As a man of class,
You apologized,
Yes, yes
And you took full responsibility.
Yes, I did. Yes, I did.
That's why it's time to reconcile.
Yes,
but before reconciliation,
Just like in a family,
when a boy does not behave too well,
we apply a little punishment.
So I'm here to punish you.
(audience applauds)
Yes, I'm here.
It's time for justice to be done.
Okay, Let's do it.
And to do this,
I will use the most hate, despise
and misunderstood animals
on earth, the insects.
The insects?
The insects, and to start with, I will put
in your hand, if you don't mind,
I don't know.
Are you ready?
Yes, I'm ready. I don't love bugs.
I'm gonna tell you right now.
That's not my problem, you must love bug.
(taller man groans)
Here's a beautiful cockroach.
Oh my God!
Yes, yes ,yes. One is not enough.
I would put you on, on your way you are
That's freaking. Just put that on me?
You're putting it on me.
If you drop them, the
punishment will be double.
Okay,
( audience shouting)
Yes, yes, yes,
That's great. That's great. That's great.
That's really great!
Now, I have here, a beautiful
walking (indistinct)
Oh my God! What is this thing right here?
Look at that!
(audience applauds)
Now, I have a giant one, you know,
a giant one.
So if you don't mind,
Okay , this is not...oh my God!
(audience applauding)
Mila kiss me.
I swear I can't.(chuckles)
Okay
[Mila] Oh my God! Let's pray.
It's time for justice, now
I have a huge (indistinct)
Why do you keep, easing your pocket?
(indistinct)
How do you get into a
restaurant. I mean, just curious.
What? I hate them all. There you are,
You hate them all...Ok,
that's, what is this?
This is a millipede.
Is that, is that right?
No, not that easy because the diminishment
is more accelerated.
I have here,
Oh my God! No, that's a tarantula.
I don't want to... no no no no...
Yes, yes, yes
No ,no no no no....
Yes, yes, yes... that's your problem.
(audience applaud)
Don't worry, don't worry,
Why are you putting it over there?
Now, the final punishment,
Can I ask you a question?
Is the venom out of the tarantula?
Deadly! I have here,
(audience applauding)
I have here,
Are you serious there's
venom the tarantula?
Now, that's a scorpion,
No, no no. Scorpion was
disgusting rehearsal.
No to the scorpion. No!
How old are you?
No!
How old am I? What does it matter?
I'm 41, but what's the point?
So young die.
No, no, no...
You said you gonna...That's got a stinger.
That's it, deadly.
But, you did well.
You're a man of courage.
(audience applaud)
Oh my God!
Aaawww (yelling). That, that...
Not my problem. Not my problem.
Look, it's on his butt right here.
Turn around, look at that.
It's all right, it's all right.
You grabbed onto your ass.
Oh where is the tarantula!
What the hell, you didn't even know
where your tarantula was still...
thank you Andy.
[Andy] You're welcome.
The one show where Andy comes back
in a couple of years and...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
(Mila yelling)
Now...
What is this? Why do you hate everybody?
I make the pretty talented girl run away
and be afraid.
Now that the is done,
I brought as a symbol,
This is beautiful butterfly a Mott,
and I will release him in this studio.
That's your problem.
(everyone applauds)
All right.
No, that's your problem. (laughs)
(indistinct)
Hey, what are you doing now?
I hugged you,
Okay.
I hugged you because...
Yeah, now we are friends.
All right, by the way,
your work inspired a new movie
called "The Blue Butterfly"
which is debuting this weekend
at the Tribeca Film Festival.
Sir, thank you very much for coming.
You're a good man. Thank you.
(audience applaud)